hey breaking news to bring to Israel's
Attorney General has indicted the Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu on multiple
corruption charges he has said that he
is not guilty in any of these cases of
course all this is happening as Israel's
in the middle of it basically a
political stalemate let's go to our
Harry faucet who's gathering more
information on this so Harry this has
kind of been hanging over Benjamin
Netanyahu said for quite a while tell us
what's happening for years indeed yes
that the corruption case the
investigation least started in December
2016 and the Attorney General
recommended that he be indicted in these
three separate corruption cases back in
February and now finally we have the
indictment now this has never happened
in Israel before that a sitting Prime
Minister has been charged with offenses
as serious as these most importantly in
one of the three cases he's been charged
with bribery so let's quickly go through
the cases in question in that case this
is known as case 4000 here in Israel
Netanyahu was alleged to have used his
power as the then communications
minister as well as Prime Minister to
give regulatory benefits to a hugely
important media magnate here at the
owner of the main telecoms company
benefits worth up to five hundred
million u.s. dollars and in return
Netanyahu according to the indictment
was demanding favorable coverage in the
online news website that was also owned
by this man Saul elevate the Attorney
General in his initial recommendation
said that an extraordinary frequent
relationship emerged between Netanyahu
his wife Sarah and the elevators they
were demanding he said things details
down to how long individual stories
would stay on the website and so as well
as bribery in this case he's been
charged with fraud and breach of trust
fraud and breach of trust also in
another case where he was alleged to
have communicated with the owner of a
very important newspaper here again
demanding favorable coverage in return
for hampering the activities of a
rival newspaper and in the third case
perhaps more straightforward and easy to
understand simply accepting and
demanding gifts both him and his wife
Sarah Netanyahu demanding gifts such as
cigars and champagne from very wealthy
individuals conflict of interest was the
key charge against him in that the
Attorney General again charging him with
fraud and breach of trust in that case
so this is an extraordinary bombshell
for Netanyahu even though we've kind of
known it's been coming especially in
recent days and as you say it comes at a
time when there is no proper formed
government Netanyahu is in charge of a
transitional government
so yeah let's talk more about that the
backdrop of all this is that yes some
things are basically it a stalemate his
Benjamin Netanyahu ever indicated that
he would ever resign if he were ever
indicted does he have to resign well he
has certainly shown no willingness to
resign whatsoever quite the reverse and
it's pretty clear that he intends to
fight on with everything he has we will
hear from him in a couple of hours at
8:30 local time but yes the question
that hangs over this in fact there are
two there's a legal question and there's
a political question when it comes to
Netanyahu's future the legal question
really revolves around a law which says
a minister must step down if indicted in
a criminal case such as this but it
doesn't specify whether that includes
the Prime Minister as well and so the
the assumption from Netanyahu and his
team is that he will be allowed to carry
on especially if Israel goes to a third
election continuing all the way through
till March as the caretaker Prime
Minister but this could be challenged in
the Supreme Court and we understand that
there are teams from various political
parties optical opponents of Netanyahu's
who stand ready to lodge an appeal with
the Supreme Court to try to get them to
rule that Netanyahu must resign as Prime
Minister while this case remains active
the other thing is the political
question whether given the seriousness
of these charges he will be able to
maintain his support especially within
his own Likud Party up until
now there has been pretty strong support
from him within the code but just today
the very day that the 21 day period has
kicked off when the opportunity for
forming a coalition government goes to
anyone in the Knesset the Israeli
Parliament who can muster enough support
on that same day
did on SAR a senior Lee could figure has
said that if Israel goes to another
round of elections he says there should
be a leadership election before that
within Likud so that he can stand to be
Prime Minister of Israel not Netanyahu
this will only strengthen his case given
that Netanyahu is now on the record
finally no questions in this at all
charged with an extremely serious crime
such as bribery along with fraud and
breach of trust
okay Harry faucet with that um that big
breaking story thank you thank you very
very much